Sáng nay, tại thủ đối hà nội, sẽ tin của cả nước, lại hội đại biểu tăng của lần thứ
mười bốn của đăng, khai mặt trọng hẹn với sự tham gia của một nguyên năm 2014,
lại diện cho hơn năm kể sáo chiệu đăng viên.
Bốn phương chấm, đòn kết, rất trủ, kỳ cơ, đột phá, phát triển,
lại hội mười bốn sáng định tư duy, tâm nhìn, nhưng quên xách chỉ lộp để vũt nước biến mạnh cho kỳ nguyên mới.
Bất biểu khai mặt đại hội, thay mặt đoàn trủ biệt,
trủ tình nước lương cường trên trọng biểu dương xức nỗ lực tần đối,
trong xức nông lòng của tần đăng, ở rất tàn quân tà,
một qua mọi khó khăn thử thách, đặc biệt là vượt qua đại dịch COVID-19,
tất tham hoạc, khiến nhiên, biến động tinh tế, chỉ chỉ tòa ngầu,
nhưng trong ôn định đời sống, khôi phục và đánh mạnh phát triển kinh tế xá hội,
thân hành thẳng lợt các một tiêu,
giềm vụ, cho đại hội lên thứ mệt bà của đàn đã đề ra,
giết là những dựng đục đột phá mạnh tính cách nạn trong năm 2020.
Cùng của Nhiệm Thinh của Nhiệm Thinh, của Nhiệm Thinh,
xưa đồng thân của xá hội và tiếp theo dân xức mạnh cho đại hội của chúng ta.
Đại hội chân trọng, như thế thân ngay và chân thành cảm ơn,
xưa thân ra đầy trách hiệm và những đông có tâm huyết sau sách của các tầng của các cấp huy,
tổ chức đàn của các đồng chi, huyên lấy đồng đàn, nhà nước, của thuần thè,
các đồng chi lắm thành phát màn, các dân chi, chi thức,
cùng đông đảo các tình lắm giết trên cả nước, đồng vào thả nước ngoài trong suốt quá trình
chuẩn bị phát kiện đại hội.
Sau muốn mấy năm, các dựng đối đường mới,
đất nước ta đã đảm những thành phy tò lớn,
và phát kiện có ý nghĩa lịch sử không cải thiệt đời sống,
nâng cao hạnh phúc của nhân dân, nâng cao tầng ý tiến,
bị hế của đất nước trên trường bốt thế,
tuy nhiên đất nước vẫn còn đối mặt của nhiều khó khăn,
thách thức và hạnh chế,
tăng trường bự dưới nước tiêm năng,
chưa thật sự bên bứng,
rồi mạnh, anh mình mạnh còn tắt nộn rất phúc tạm,
sẽ không theo nhiều hệ luy, trong bụt cạnh đó,
nhân dân cả nước đất đặt nhiều khi vọng và đi quyết sách lúng đắn,
mạnh mẽ đôi phá và hiệu quà của đam tại lại hộ mi muốn.
Già hoàn mạnh, phần viên, văn viên,
tại hộ mi muốn có suy mạnh lịch sử rất or lần,
không chỉ để ra một kêu đến hướng trong giềm vô trong giềm khi,
hành hệ sáo, hành và mưa hệ.
Mà còn quyết định những vấn đề mắt tầm chí lọc,
đối với tuy nhiên và vành mạnh của sinh tập ta trong nhiều thật biệt tối,
nhằm thiết tục hơi dậy mạnh mẽ các vọng phát triển,
niềm tự hào, gí chỉ tự lực tự cường rất tộc,
khơi thông hoàn ngồi lực, mòi đồng lực phát triển,
phát viên sức mạnh nhất dân và khối đại hần phép tỏa rất tộc,
kết hợp với sức mạnh của thật lại,
đầy mạnh phát triển, đồng bộ có cực đổi mấy,
xây dân của bảo vệ tộc quốc,
và anh thành tháng lợi một tiêu phát triển đất hông cường,
sánh vai với các cường của nằm châu,
như tông viên của chúng ta hầu chi Minh và hướng phòng của tọn rất tộc Việt Nam chú trạng.
Một cộng phòng phòng xôi chúng như...
Bỏ cảo vệ các bất kịt chính đại hộ miếp bốn của đàn,
tổng mý thư tôn lâm khẳng định,
các quả tọn dịt của nhệm ki lại hộ miếp bà tiếp tục hằng miệng bài tròn lãnh đạo và ý tính của đàn,
niềm tiên của nhân dân đối với đàn, nhà nước và xây độ ngay càng đực bù đáp phức chát,
sạo tiên đề hộng bài đất nước đất bảo ra đạn thích chính mối,
bởi khi thế mối, quết tâm mối và xác bọc mối.